what happened in the past five six years
is that all the wars and changes in the
Middle East actually strengthened Iran's
position Iran is sort of emerged if you
would as a great power in the region now
there are many people who say that's not
really true this is nothing that Iran
did that gave it this status it actually
is a weak country it has a weak economy
it has a divided society all of that
might be true but it takes ten minutes
being in the Middle East to know that
the Iranians think they're a great power
and the Arabs around them think they're
a great power and a lot of politics is
about perception
the perception in the region is that the
glass is half-full for Iran is
half-empty for the Arab world that
compared to 2001 or 2002 Iran's
influence in the region is expanded and
the influence that the Arab world has
declined that Iran militarily feels it
has much more elbow room if the US
wasn't there the Arab countries now feel
vulnerable that Iran has effectively
penetrated the Arab world it controls
southern Iraq it wields a lot of
influence in Iraq Iran is big player now
in Lebanon much more so than before 2006
and look the Palestinians are not
completely divided into two territories
and guess what the Arab governments are
only influential in one territory and
the Iranians are more influential in the
other one Iran has a lot more influence
than it had in the past there's much
more capability it had in the past the
other issues are really a reaction or a
reflection of this known as the
sectarian issues becoming more important
because it falls right in the middle of
an Iranian Arab rivalry the language of
the Arabs in the region is anti Iran
anti-shia yeah and so long as the
Iranians and the Arabs are in this
rivalry Iranians are she as most of the
Arabs are Sunni sectarianism is an issue
so is Iranian Arab relations is an issue
nationalism becomes very important the
other issues even the Palestinian issue
is become now a political football
between Arabs and Iranians
I mean people argue that the whole
purpose for an Annapolis conference and
a new peace effort was to create
a United Arab front against Iran so Iran
was really the ulterior motive the
bigger the bigger fish in the picture
now for everybody in the region
Iran poses a challenge for the Arab
countries this is classical balance of
power issue it's not necessarily just
about the Iranian regime it's a country
of 70 million people very wealthy very
large very nationalistic with imperial
ambitions going back to the Shahs period
it's now feels that it's been let loose
in the Persian Gulf and any country
whether it's Egypt Saudi Arabia UAE any
country reacts to a relative loss of
power with anxiety so everybody looks
and says can we go back to a rebalancing
Iran that's a natural reaction the
United States has a challenge because
the United States were a very long time
invested in a vision of the Middle East
which was based on the idea that the
Arab world is the most dominant factor
and stability in the Middle East depends
on stability in the Arab world
now all of a sudden we see that Iran is
a lot more important from Lebanon to
Palestine issue two particularly the
Persian Gulf where everything we care
about right now is over there and to
Iraq which is our most important you
know issue in the region now all of a
sudden the Arab world that we invested
so much in is not able to control and
influence and shape things to the extent
that was the case five years ago we have
to play catch-up with reality now one of
the ways in which the Bush
administration is trying to do this is
to take the clock back to 2002 that's
not going to happen easily bloodlessly
effortlessly iran's not going to go back
in its cage easily the question is can
we cobble together a new framework for
the region that deals with the reality
which is Iran is more influential Arabs
maybe a little less come to a new
balance
for Israel the problem is very different
Israel and Iran now essentially are the
two great powers in this region the Arab
world is sandwiched between you you had
it for a period but a unipolar situation
in the Middle East well Israel was
conventional military dominant the Arab
world by and large was becoming an ally
of the u.s. Syria or Libya were not
mattering much Iraq was broken down by
the u.s. Iran all of a sudden has
emerged as the counterweight to Israel
it's trying to shore up the Arab Street
against Israel very Yulin rhetoric
against Israel anti Holocaust rhetoric
pro-palestinian rhetoric rejecting
talking etc and it's trying to woo the
Arab world away from Israel and Israel
in the United States are trying to woo
the Arab world against Iran but that
means that the real power players are
not the Arab or the Arab world is the
prize in a bigger fight between Israel
and Iran over power in this region
now Israel whenever you have nuclear
capability there's always a fear about
its use but I don't think that's the
really most important issue here I mean
look at South Asia Pakistan and India
hate one another they have a live issue
between them called Kashmir ever since
they've gone nuclear
they haven't gone to war one another
there is a nuclear peace in southeast
South Asia now but but but the reality
is that the issue is a bit more complex
it's not that whether Iran the minute it
gets the bomb is going to launch it
first of all Iran is many years away
from a bomb and many were years away
from getting parity with Israel which
has some 200 nuclear weapons and second
strike capability the reality is that
when Indian Pakistan each one nuclear
they went different paths
India relaxed began to focus on economic
growth and real things Pakistan became
much more dangerous became much more
adventurous take it would send jihadi
fighters into Kashmir and Afghanistan
and even right now the Pakistanis do
things that other countries would not
get away with against the United States
was giving you money
why because they believe that they have
some kind of immunity because of the
nuclear capability India will not invade
Pakistan even though it has a bigger
army now the question is which one will
Iran be will Iran be India or will Iran
be Pakistan and then the bigger question
is an Iranian bomb will play the same
role that American nuclear weapons
played in Europe during the Cold War the
Soviets had many more tanks many more
soldiers they could have just walked
into Western Europe we couldn't match
their numbers but once you have the
nuclear weapons in the picture
conventional superiority becomes
irrelevant the new nuclear weapons are
an equalizer for in the minds of Middle
Eastern countries Israel has absolute
conventional superiority it is a
fantastic military which has proven
itself in war is highly technologically
advanced and he has a superb Air Force
now the minute you have a nuclear
capability all of that conventional
superiority will become irrelevant
so for Israel and nuclear Iran is an
absolute strategic loss I'm not
convinced that there will be nuclear war
and one never knows but I do not
convinced that that's the the most
likely scenario the most likely outcome
but you one can be absolutely sure and
once Iran has a nuclear weapon Israel
will lose its conventional superiority
and the balance of power in the region
will shift Israel will not be able to
for instance operate in Syria or in
south Lebanon with the ease that it does
many Arab countries that right now
complain about Iranian nuclear weapons
may actually benefit from a nuclear
shield and become a lot more and he's
really and and if you you'll end up with
a much more with it with a much more
constricted Israel in a in a Middle East
which still has many life unresolved
issues that threaten Israel's security